bonjour voyez vous au paranormal aux
esprits vengeurs aux fantômes j'hésitais
à plus cette vidéo et c'est de ne pas
avoir peur puis je me suis souvenu pour
public était composé de frossard qui
n'auraient pas cliqué par peur de faire
une crise cardiaque
les amis aujourd'hui c'est un énorme qui
fait qu'on va faire on va regarder
ensemble des vraies vidéos qui prennent
en flagrant délit d' des apparitions
paranormal voici la vidéo rial gosse
quand un tel montage qui a donc dix
mille j'aime pas on part donc sur des
vidéos fait qu'à mon avis mais bon on va
regarder ça et décrypté voici c'est du
fake ou pas ensemble mais que j'ai passé
des dizaines de sourds à faire ça tout
seul jusqu'à 3 heures du matin je
faisais pas l'amour à l'époque a'salfo
te le dire c'est parti
[Musique]
elle est drôle c'est à du jeu y'a quand
même si la meuf est pas là d'un coup
c'est pas aussi jamais ça c'est la
technique la plus facile pour faire
croire des apparitions de fantômes s'est
demandé à ta petite fille asiatique de 6
en calèche peu plus noir que la mousse
de ce micro de se mettre à la porte puis
de courir en haut des marches la meuf
cours puis elle refait la scène avec sa
fille cette fois qu'ils ont des marches
elle repart du même endroit et on fera
encore images je suis désolé brisé mon
rêve mais je suis une énorme maire de
fléchettes bien que j'aime ça et c'est
le trucage qu'on a utilisées dans cette
vidéo la avec clément si tu regardes
image par image qui arrive à peu près à
voir deux images qui normandes se
suivent pas c'est un raccord bref cette
fois la vidéo était à chier deuxième
vidéo
[Musique]
alors cet effet donc là y'a quelqu'un on
le voit bien évidemment il est énorme
bref il est là il avance et il ya une
sorte de traîner derrière trenet qui
s'apparente finalement un effet de
duplication sur windows movie maker des
faits très simple sauf qu'il est de très
loin donc on croit forcément que c'est
un fantôme de faire du blizzard on joue
je suis lente et c'est exactement ce qui
se passe avec cette personne dans cette
vidéo pourtant je suis très fragile
croit mort assurent de trucs mais là
faut pas se [ __ ] de la gueule de l'ue
aux chars suivant au nom ça j'aime pas
j'aime pas du tout depuis quand y avoir
comme ça dans une maison d'arrêt les
gars tu veux être crédible arrêté aussi
à ça bouge assez lui convoi d'une autre
caméra moi c'est très bien fait c'est
très bien fait c'est juste une nombre sa
passion sur photoshop pour la bonne
nouvelle c'est que j'ai trouvé la source
du bruit ce ventilateur du sinn voilà un
bon élucidé mystère ok attention vidéo
suivante
[Musique]
allez gaye s'est pas fait chier quoi
elle a juste des tours et sa fille il a
ajouté un petit effet de transparence
c'est un fantôme ça passe ça y est j'ai
fait les fixes de insidious et de
conjurer les dossiers douanes verront
que du feu
ac les je suis offusqué insolite bleus
qui arrivent et qui a atterri et qui a
une forme humaine alors là attention je
m'engage à faire un montage aussi fort
que celui ci par mes propres moyens
c'est parti talentueux ou pas bon je me
suis pas ton cas c'est que tu as à
ternir l'image et à la rendre plus
dégueulasse qu'elle l'est de base comme
la technique du magret vidéo bien
évidemment j'ai pris un solide double
jeu les détours et j'avais la flemme de
le faire changer de formes en mouvement
parce que ça casse les coups ça m'aurait
pris du temps là ce texte ordinaire
c'est l'interview d'excusés suivant ça
c'est de bien pourri ça ça va être bien
bien courir
[Musique]
voilà quand papa sait plus comment faire
plaisir à sa fille est ma fille on va
faire genre ton reflet c'est un fantôme
d'allumer leur coupe du monde
je sais encore t'as pas vu mon skill sur
photoshop voilà j'avais pas de faim deux
à la salle air sérieux là qu'est ce que
c'est
[Musique]
aussi hilarant but toutes les vidéos que
j'ai regardé comme ça de ma vie c'est la
poussière au jour fait chevalier de vous
la faire celle là c'est parti
[Musique]
je sais ce que vous pensez c'était
fidèle à l'original là franchement c'est
plus honteux pas je l'europe c'est à
crocs comme ces groupes total de merde
ça dégage fait nous vibrer à cela chante
j'ai déjà vu des hypers banon vous avez
quelqu'un la fenêtre veille comme par
hasard c'est toujours bon je passais du
feq bogard mais star fout là ça fait un
peu peur je me dis pourquoi les photos
ils ont toujours filmé par une photo non
mais c'est vrai c'est jamais un bon sony
alpha cet été ce qui m'a filmé ça ou une
raide sur un tournage de film à l'arrêt
n'y a jamais un fauteuil qui a passé les
trades show filmé avec avec un sablier
mon gars j'ai un pas de calais il est là
il faut que sert à quelque chose
suivant encore une ombre à non juste un
mec qui joue avec sa housse de couette
blanche mais non mme ndiaye c'est un
cours du mec fait tous plus hilarants
lot no comète de comètes n'avait mieux
mieux vaut pour lui qu'on commande de
feu à tamedia c'est le décor d'un film
d'horreur le jouet qui se balancent tout
seul plus la chaise de la grand-mère
décédée sur cette même chaise de jours
avant à minuit après avoir dit trois
fois dame blanche si le truc qui fait
peur c'est juste la chaise qui bouge
tout seul
il m'a fait peur le courant allez on
continue on continue c'est roncquois
vidéo contient des flashs des lay des
bruits des trucs jump scare ce parti a
tout doux tout pour qu'on crève
ah ça c'est vrai à ces accords les
exporations pour ça mais c'est tellement
le cerveau que tu n'as pas envie qu'il
se passe la chaîne elles bougent et tout
ça à prémesques j'avoue ça peut être
l'un d'eux ça peut être un gros coup à
mener en coup de vent un cyclone qui
passe à quelques centimètres du mec du
coup il ne sent pas assez en plus dans
les mines et où il ya eu tellement de
morts un lieu hanté souvent c'est lié au
fait qu'ils aient eu beaucoup de morts
du coup on dit qu'il est hantée
finalement ça fait un peu peur de la
mort c'est beau ce que je dis là elle
mais elle dit que la température
ambiante a chuté autour de lui et ça
c'est horrible s'est pas tu peux pas
savoir si c'est parce que le mec il est
entre autres parce qu'il ya un devoir
une chaîne bouger tout seul donc il en
peut plus de sa vie en mode à et du coup
il a froid etc
ou alors si c'est vraiment un petit
gobelet comme ça un fantôme gobelins moi
j'ai des gobelins il ya poussé la chaîne
comme ça tu as froid vannes ans chez ba
ok mais deux suivantes un mec qui
travaille dans un truc qui vend des dvd
ou des niches et pas trop et apparemment
un objet va bouger tout seul au choqué
[Musique]
c'est très bas dans très très bas dans
ma pré sur la piste on met tout ça je me
dira c'est ce que ce matin michael
changement point quitte la chaîne
monoprix chez monoprix tout de suite non
pas une troisième fois une troisième
fois c'est c'est abusé le mec qui
restent sur 11 a abusé je serais parti
en couille mon gars je râle schopenhauer
la caméra surveillance comme ça pour
faire un petit buzz je suis battu par
exemple criant abonnez vous c'est chaud
de feu est un cas typique on voi le mec
qui l'ont x 20 et du coup tu vois plus
que des piquets je vous ai dit [ __ ]
mais filmer en hd pourquoi les gens qui
fut le moi je dis visa - y'a jamais
d'apparition ça m'énerve ampute un mois
c'est pas le moment
ça fout là alors c'est une fille assise
sur sa chaise tout seul
sa part bouger il va pas lui faire la
blague de tirer sa chaise elle pour
qu'elle tombe à ce serait drôle c'est un
fantôme un clown quoi ah ouais lui fut
pas encore
tu attends attends à ce sujet que revoir
par contre c'est un peu too much
bats toi c'est 28 carrément et ça coûte
une volée partout dans la salle
après ça peut être agressés ça peut être
un fait qu'ils ont accès au chaos calme
en tueur ayant si ça lui met en place un
truc assez horrible bon jeolla d'herbe
animal je propose qu'on arrête
maintenant il faut posséder bien
franchement j'en rigole mais j'me chie
dessus je me pisse dessus
j'aurais jamais eu le courage de faire
des explorations nocturne comme un
meeting fut quand même le grand jd à
fait unique à râler sur l'île de pau
veglia j'ai envie d'y croire mais dès
qu'il ya tout qui me montrent qu'il faut
y croire je n'y crois quand même pas
excusé on est tous dans ce cas là c'est
terrible
bref j'espère vous êtes bien vient
pisser dessus 1 au final est ce qu'on
n'a pas plus par la fin de cette vidéo
qu'à la fin d'un jeu d'horreur c'est bon
on a testé pas mal d'hommes ça vous a
plus à fait stupide cette fin celio ça
fait super longtemps que jouer la ferme
jamais pris mes couilles pour les poser
comme ça sur la table assez de bruit
qu'elles font quand je dépose qui sont
très très lourd des normes plus
talentueux prochaine même si vous
regardez portez vous bien des gens du
monde miss
[Musique]
ça